[Musique]
le conseil départemental à célébrer
l'aïd ce dimanche 1er juillet dans les
jardins de la villa du département
les invités ont pu profiter de divers
spectacles ou encore d'ateliers tels que
le traditionnel aînés ou encore la
calligraphie une journée festive et
conviviale
je tiens à quoi une fois renouvelées
tous mes souhaits à l'ensemble des
réunionnaises et réunionnais veut en
particulier à ceux qui sont de
confession musulmane en lui en le disant
joyeuses fêtes de lège ici à la réunion
je les dis ce qui fait notre force et
notre vivre ensemble il nous convient de
préserver cette qualité de vie cette
harmonie de vie et en ma qualité de
président du département je fais la
promotion de ce travail qui consiste à
consolider nos liens
un vrai modèle de savoir vivre ensemble
propre à la réunion qu'il faut préserver
selon houssen amode président du conseil
régional du culte musulman la laïcité
elle est bien comprise puisque la loi de
séparation des églises et de laïcité
mais n'exclut pas la religion interdit
le prosélytisme était dit certains
manifestation de la religion lorsque
c'est intempestifs mais la religion est
un est un fait est une réalité qu'il
faut absolument aujourd'hui prendre en
compte parce que à la porte des valeurs
mais quand elle est fêtée comme ça par
la mairie les collectivités du
département la région
c'est parce que c'est sa dimension
également culturel est également de
reconnaître un petit peu les origines
mais ceci étant comme je les dis aussi
dans mon propos tout à l'heure tous à
des réunionnais j'en ai deux partagent
bien représentatif du mois sacré de
ramadan
[Musique]
là